obviously as a fan of some show on HBO I
am curious what it's been like filming
the new season and um are you what are
you excited for
uh succession is great uh is it called
succession succession yeah that's the
name for the fourth season we'll do yeah
we're going to keep it the same uh it's
just great it's just a blast you know
um
I don't know there's there's we just
have such a great Rhythm together the
writing is excellent it's just the
season is next level it's like it's an
incredible I'm very very impressed every
time we get a script I mean I always
have been but like this season they
continue to be I'm like Jesus Christ
this is like unbelievable so it
continues to be like a total joy to make